so usually on this channel we talk about
technology in all sorts of different
forms we talk about brand-new phones
coming out like the Samsung edge 20 or
some of the best laptops on the market
like the surface laptop 3 how that today
I'm going to be talking about something
that you as the general public searches
the most on Google so one of the main
things that everybody keep searching on
Google is how do they connect their air
pods to basically any device that you
own right now in 2020 what's going on
guys
my name is David Thomas and welcome back
to the channel being a long weekend I've
tried to be super productive with my
time this time around instead of just
lazing around and doing absolutely
nothing
so this long weekend I decided to take
my years of e-commerce knowledge put it
together into a free pdf for people who
are interested in starting a side hustle
so if it's something that interested you
check out the first link in the
description below and maybe it might be
something that will inspire you to start
your very first ecommerce store in 2020
anyway let's get on to how you can
connect a set of ear pods be it 1 2 or
the pro to any device that you may own
right now so straight off the bat the
Apple earpods are designed to work with
Apple products and they're the easiest
to connect with Apple products so if you
have an iPhone it's as simple as opening
the case placing them next to it and
waiting for the air pod little emoji to
pop up and click and connect the process
is also identical with any iPad that you
might own as well having said that you
can also connect it to a Samsung device
so I am predominantly a Samsung user and
it is very very easy to set up on your
Samsung devices all we have to do is
pull the little tab down press and hold
the Bluetooth button to jump it straight
into your Bluetooth settings open the
case again very similar and wait for the
Bluetooth connection to pop up mine was
already connected on my phone so is it
automatically connecting as I open the
case it's just as simple as this guy's
to connect it to any laptop or any
MacBook that you might
so if you own a MacBook Pro for example
like the one I'm showing in this video
all we have to do is go command and
space type in Bluetooth and go to your
main Bluetooth settings it'll
automatically begin searching for new
devices that your laptop can get to so
again open your ear pods wait for the
Bluetooth signal to connect to your
computer and then simply connect by
pressing on your ear pods that you're
looking for the process has a few more
steps if you're looking to connect it to
a Windows PC or to a surface laptop 3
like I'm demonstrating here it's not
actually too hard or too much of a big
deal
all you have to do is go to the bottom
search bar and type in Bluetooth to open
up your Bluetooth settings from here you
have to go the 1 step further and click
add new Bluetooth device and then add a
bluetooth mouse keyboard etc open the
air pods and wait for it to show up once
it shows up you simply click on it again
and then go through the steps but really
it is that simple now if you're using an
older computer or a computer that
doesn't have bluetooth well do not worry
you haven't gone away stood a couple
hundred dollars on air pods and not able
to use them on your computer you can
easily jump on eBay or Amazon or any of
those sites and order a really cheap
bluetooth dongle I think it costs you
about two three dollars I'll link it in
the description for you guys as well
that way you can easily just ship out a
little dongle to you plug it into a USB
port on your computer and pretty much in
seconds go to your Bluetooth settings
and connect these air pods
there's no other major work to be done
most of these Bluetooth dongles
automatically either download a driver
to your computer or don't need any
drivers at all so you can quickly and
easily get air pods up and running but
this is something to take note of if you
do already know that you don't have a
computer with bluetooth so when you go
to buy these air pods make sure that you
buy the bluetooth dongle beforehand so
it arrives before these headphones get
to you otherwise you're going to be a
little bit disappointed that you can't
use these headphones with your computer
and that's all I have for you guys today
a very simple quick and easy tutorial
but one of the
most searched tutorials online in 2020
which is astonishing to me but hey
everybody's different and everybody
needs to know the information thankfully
YouTube makes it super easy to find out
what you need so thanks so much for
watching and as always I'll see you next
Monday